boa tarde gente de bom
quem é que ansioso é verdade que não
levantou a mão pode levantar que todo
mundo aqui e ansioso eu sou muito
ansioso e quando recebi o convite para
palestrar aqui no pé de hoje
essa ansiedade triplicou quadriplicou
multiplicou eu fiquei desesperado
essa é a verdade eu sou muito fã do ted
sempre foi um sonho e eventualmente
participar de um assistindo netflix no
youtube e no site estaria agora em casa
assistindo ao vivo também obrigado
e aí quando eu soube do convite está bom
mas ainda não é aquela sobre o convite
eu falei cara ao mesmo tempo é um sonho
realizado
você tem aquela bela máxima não posso
errar diante de vocês diante de quem
está assistindo em casa quando o cara
falou que 20.000 fiquei mais nervoso
ainda pensei eu preciso de alguma de
algum artifício para me relaxar
lá na hora eu tive idéia maluca de botar
esse primeiro slide
quando cheguei aqui ontem à marcel aqui
tá sendo um anjo ela já 20 mil
apresentações como todo dia tem uma
idéia nova
arnaldo eu acho que você errou você
motor ligado primeiro falei cá tem todo
o motivo
a minha ideia maluca eu preciso muito
que vocês apostam nela que vocês me
ajudem nisso é o seguinte sempre acaba
para essa galera pode ficar mais
tranqüilo então vou fingir agora que
parece está acabando
vou agradecer se você não pode nem vou
sair correndo porque você é a coisa mais
importante na minha vida têm vocês 20
mil pessoas assistindo então assim calma
calma campeão tem que ser tipo assim a
subir o outro tira a camisa e e está
calma agora tá aí então a gente obrigado
[Aplausos]
obrigada na vanguarda que ó poço
funcionou
obrigado realmente mais tranquilo além
da da brincadeira e do artifício que
realmente funcionou é nunca é de mais
agradecer
eu acho que é obrigada a palavra que
mais falta na minha vida sem dúvida e
não é demais acontecer agora já no
início a presença de vocês
a galera tá assistindo o pessoal da ibm
está sendo nota 1000 comigo então além
da brincadeira que funciona muito
obrigado pela presença e pela ajuda
porto
bom é não bastou essa brincadeira no
início para eu saber o que queria falar
aqui hoje eu tô acostumada a fazer parte
de mais ou menos uma hora
fica aqui eu posso andar tranquilo possa
apertar mais pra cá é não eu gosto de
andar lá pra baixo e possuir a então vou
ficar aqui é é cara que eu vou ficar se
dando volta disse
quando eu vi que ele sempre aparece de
uma hora eu falo muito se deve ter
percebido para botar em 15 20 minutos e
ainda conectar isso com o despertar que
é o tema do ted
falei meu deus que vou fazer peguei essa
frase do victor que recebeu muito
gentilmente uma frase maravilhosa
nela eu comecei a achar um caminho
queremos que aqueles que saem do
auditório da smec e estejam com vontade
incontrolável de mudar um único que me
deu eu automaticamente me identifiquei
com isso eu sempre uma criança quis
mudar o mundo que eu vivi e eu nunca
achei que isso fosse acontecer através
de faculdade vestibular enem empresa
jorge um cliente sempre achei que até um
caminho mais do que especial diferente
das pessoas
meu primeiro devaneio foi desde pequeno
eu sonhei ser o camisa 10 do flamengo
estou aqui não estou na concentração
para o jogo contra o botafogo é daqui a
pouco então obviamente não deu certo mas
a verdade é que temos 16 anos eu não
tava nem aí pro colégio achava que o
futebol e se a minha vida que
eventualmente um dia as coisas vão
acontecer naturalmente eu ia pro
flamengo depois é que o time europeu
para encerrar a carreira aqui é virar
comentarista e até um carro branco e srs
a verdade é que eu percebi que não era
bom o suficiente
em meu primeiro devaneio de ser especial
digamos assim foi por água abaixo o
sport continua sendo para mim é uma
predileção depois do futebol tentei
basquete e se não durou nem tão porque
eu não tenho altura não tem habilidade
não tem nada só tem só gosta de assistir
realmente jogo mas durou muito pouco
um terceiro de janeiro que foi a música
eu não vou cantar para vocês entenderem
porque não deu certo mas não deu certo
essa minha mão pequena também alcança
daccord enfim no futebol foi o que
chegou mais perto mas nenhum desses deu
certo e aí 18 anos vestibular chegando
têm que vou fazer não faço a mínima
ideia arnaldo você é comunicativo faz
comunicação ok
minha preparação foi essa comunicação
fiz um ano na puc onde o ps pm fez um
ano onde e voltei pra pouco foi mais um
ano onde larguei no formato calma gente
eu não me formei até hoje não têm
diploma
tenho projeto de voltar mas agora a
empresa já com quatro anos de mercado
fala dela em breve
eu não tenho tempo não torço gêneros pra
ninguém
meu caminho eu tive algumas sorte no
caminho que ser muito bem cercado de
pessoas competentes
a verdade é que a formação acadêmica me
faz falta até hoje mas eu não consigo me
dedicar a uma coisa que me faça feliz e
realmente não acho que meu caminho na
faculdade que eu fiz naquele momento
acho sim que hoje em dia tensão do
momento o eu estava mais em mim do que a
dificuldade pela falta de maturidade na
verdade foi que eu liguei e falei vou
tocar minha vida
e aí por exemplo da minha família
comecei a trabalhar com festa você
imagina o que não foi lá em casa
o caso depois de três faculdades
incompletas começou a fazer festa no rio
de janeiro
o site amigos e da manhã o hulk é embora
esse mercado seja visto um pouco de
preconceito mas eu entendo é você dorme
tarde você ganha um dia perde o outro
foi a primeira vez que eu comecei a ter
contato com o que realmente tinha
vontade de fazer poder realizar algo
criativo
o poder implementar uma ideia de poder
conhecer gente legal
conheci muita gente boa fiz um bom
dinheiro só que isso não tinha muito a
ver comigo
vocês viram que tem muito a ver com
esporte eu gosto de acordar cedo gosto
de procurar correr com a jogar futebol e
de basquete pode movimentar bem e eu
falei cara não consigo mais seguir essa
rotina de madrugada todos os dias e aí
eu tive um novo raúl teve o pulo do gato
de falar cada divulgar o evento em 2010
já era trabalhar com rede social eu
trabalhava muito com o facebook nessa
época pouca gente conhecia o facebook
mas eu estudei muito a ferramenta pra
poder jogar mais eventos passei a usar
isso no 'hall' para clientes que eu
tinha conhecido no mercado de eventos
então como é normal do facebook e
adquirir com eventos e oferecer pra mode
ou pouco mais comprava pra academia que
eu morava por hoje toda a economia
no começo a gente pagava com permuta
então pagava mais pra comer pra malhar
para investir não leva nada mas com o
tempo o mercado foi crescendo meu
conhecimento foi crescendo e se a gente
começar a me indicar entre si
e aí eu comecei até 10 12 clientes e
chegou a hora de fazer o negócio ficar
sério e aí surgiu hqt que significou que
tal
hoje temos quatro anos de mercado 60
clientes três funcionários mas nosso
principal índice de sucesso ea
felicidade
somos muito felizes se não fossemos não
adiantaria nada isso que eu falei pra
vocês bom beleza montando que o ted eu
mostrei pra vocês um pouco de emoção
infância agora vou esquecer na minha
empresa para ver se eu consigo fazer uma
conexão das minhas missões com o mercado
mas ainda faltava um link com o tal
despertar que é o tema do ted né
e aí vocês podem pensar caramba o menino
tinha um sonho em jogar futebol e jogar
basquete cantar com a banda de rock
enfim os sonhos dele foram por água
abaixo ele teve as asas cortadas
pode ser vamos ver
o primeiro grande case da empresa que eu
consigo me lembrar foi reduzido
eles conhecem os riscos que ele está
acima de qualquer tinham de qualquer
tipo de fanatismo é em novembro de 2012
a gente se ligou ele faria 60 anos em
março do ano que vem e que o facebook
estava abandonada
coincidentemente eu tinha um contato que
conhece o empresário dele e esse contato
e passou e meu empresário dele e eu
mandei email atrás de 636 atendimentos
que o cara tem um cara um dia me
respondeu colocar você pode ter uma
reunião na casa do músico óbvio a hora o
dia se quiser você quiser eu vou já no
milho embora marcou a reunião eu cheguei
lá de cara dura
a lei zico que faz uma promoção no seu
facebook e durante o mês de dezembro
será diferente de natal por seus
seguidores que os 20 caras que mais
interagiu com a página é bom jogar uma
pelada com você não tem adversários fc
paulo os cinco segundos até hoje o cabo
para responder foi o tempo mais rápido
na minha vida porque eu não sabia se ia
falar que eu era um completo lunático de
chegar ali mal conhece ele já oferecer
essa campanha ousada ou se ele gostar
ele gostou a campanha foi uma loucura é
a campanha acaba dia 25 de dezembro à
meia noite e meia noite o vídeo de um
aplicativo no facebook na época chamado
top fãs que você conseguir mensurar a
que mais interagiu com a página e aí o
20º e 21º ficavam trocando assim foi
cara errou não vamos dar um presente a
quem liga para a nasa para mostrar o
segundo certinho que esse cara conseguiu
fazer
acabou que no dia do jogo vencido pelo
foi reclamou não porque eu fiquei na
seca obviamente o cara jogou
obviamente que eu também joguei eu tô
aqui ó trabalho no banco esperando
alguém se machucar que vai aquecendo o
primeiro que cansou é fui lá então
joguei com zico
joguei com os fãs do zico foi um sonho
para ele certamente foi um sonho pra mim
não deixa de ser um sonho cruzeiro
também está em contato com essa galera
que tanto ama ele isso foi o primeiro
grande case que a gente fez na empresa
em 2013
é claro que teve a parte da felicidade e
sempre é o que vai me mover que sempre
vai me falar se o tempo fosse a ação mas
em termos de números em termos de
estatística
o pré requisito para quem vai acontecer
era para chegar a um milhão de
seguidores ela tinha 200 mil e eles não
tinham verba para impulsionar a paz
chegou a um milhão e meio de seguidores
de maneira orgânica
quem mexe com o facebook sabe o quão
difícil é isso na época era mais fácil
engenheiros até dificultar ainda mais o
alcance orgânico mas ainda assim foi um
grande case então empolgado com essa
história de me aproximar do esporte
através da do meu trabalho trabalho na
empresa
no ano seguinte em 2014 ano de copa do
mundo todo mundo lembra eu descobrir que
a história de gay estava no shopping
leblon e na época trabalhava até junho o
shopping leblon
cheguei mariko e fica na porta
tudo bom prazer só ronaldo olha eu sou
muito sangue eu tenho uma agência que
faz isso mas tenho que reduzir que é um
abrir muitas portas e eu estou aqui à
disposição para ajudar vocês como vocês
quiserem a gente não tem água não tem
problema
no quesito zico também não teve um
envolvido em um problema eu amo isso eu
quero muito poder ajudar tá bom tá
beleza gostei então pensa em alguma
coisa pra fazer pra mim e volta semana
que vem com a apresentação que eu vou
estar aqui com os carros estados unidos
salvou
aí comecei a pesquisar de cada time está
muito fraco embora o facebook fosse já
bom
a idéia que a gente teve foi vamos
durante a copa
falar para as pessoas que forem ver o
jogo do brasil e com a camisa do lakers
e amarela que foi o jogo da bélgica que
é vermelha
a minha primeira vamos ver como ficará o
uso de ipod na foto com a hashtag no
brasil
de cara dourada é mais uma vez não podia
a gente chamou algumas pessoas muito
relevantes no mercado do basquete e com
bastante seguidor no estado durante a
época para poder começar por essa
campanha make a gente controlando isso
cara vai lá a moça tem camisa não tirou
a camisa ficou na casa do cara da camisa
para ele o cara foi de jogo tirou o
resultado disso foi incrível a campanha
bongô mesmo durante a copa que é o
período no qual o futebol está muito
mais em voga por motivos óbvios e
coincidentemente logo acabou
foi dada a notícia que o rio de janeiro
é sediar um jogo de basquete lnb e entre
miami heat e cleveland cavaliers se que
onde jogo lebron james que é meu ídolo
no esporte assim mais do que futebol
mais que qualquer outro
lembram pra mim é o cara
sim admiro muito quando fiquei sabendo
disso falei pô cara de brasil pra ele é
gay e eu faço é grande e vou conhecer o
cara
o aeroporto estava lá
o hotel reto treino reto jogo reto cara
tava indo embora do brasil ele veio pra
minha cidade eu estava trabalhando pra
ele que ele joga e eu não tinha visto
ainda e eu já tava em casa desolado com
a história até que tipo no último dia
domingo 8 da noite e 47 segundo tempo
comigo cara da adidas para assim ronaldo
vai ter uma festa de despedida na
pastelaria e vem vem vem agora fui
correndo
cheguei no parque lá jamais de convite a
apom entrei
cheguei no parque lage não sei quanto
vocês conhecem bem mas nomes como ben
laden
o spot carwin entre os jogadores antigos
gary payton se limitavam assim parece um
boneco de ser o cara tava no não saibam
assim sozinho sem ninguém digitar essa
maturidade e no índice que falando que
todo mundo já no celf tal não se equipou
aquele cara que entrou de penetra não
podia fazer uma cena não estava nem aí
nada de bronca
lebron e aí a minha felicidade de ver
esses caras foi se transformando
nervosismo porque o lebron estava agora
qualquer momento embora não sei que já
foi no parque lage mas sabe quando
começa a música muita festa mas jono
sofreu essas coisas ea luz começou a
ascender a essa festa vai acabar corrida
começou a acabar bebida na secretária
eletrônica do banco e levaram nada de
lebron
sentei no meio fio limpeza no parque
lage na saída do caso à noite na piscina
quando chegou a casa com outro maluco
estava também atrair lebron sem ter que
ficar a ficar assim não cara é porque
senão na bíblia cara bem na minha cidade
no verão fica assim sim
enquanto estou falando isso horizonte
esse deus de abandono de 2016 vem
andando na minha direção
peguei meu celular a deputada foi o
irmão prepara essa câmera aí vou ficar
na frente dele mesmo quando ele pisar em
mim para mas gostei então você filma aí
vem andando aqui lembro na minha direção
ele o segurança foi expulso do aeroporto
do treino do hotel para aí parei para
que este papa a isso lembrou a segurança
nem se fala na frente segurança também é
assim
lebron esse moleque não vai desistir
tirou a força foto com ele
a smte assim o que me dói
ele está ajoelhada 15 cm de tamanho dele
esse foi o único sorriso que esse
desgraçado do rio foi do meu lado e
assim acabou ele passou fiquei uns dois
segundos simples reação acabou e
comemorava a ser moleque não sei que foi
maravilhoso mas de novo além do meu
sonho realizado também teve a parte
mercadológica parte de métrica de
números da coisa porque é a nossa
hashtag durante a copa começou a
movimentar durante esse jogo explodiu os
caras do nbb e americana
apostar numa cidade entrou no treino do
flamengo levou um cartaz criou a hashtag
de outros caras as cartas publicadas no
resultado um mês depois eu fui para nova
iorque convidado pela unb para
apresentar o case pra eles eles
replicaram pra lá
obviamente não conhece o time b no
brasil com as tags vai play
então eu falo assim o técnico eu fui
para nova york apresentavam que explicar
esses caras fizeram igual foi assim
surreal maravilhoso o terceiro que é
isso que eu tenho muito carinho da minha
empresa é o case dos 30 anos do cazuza
ano passado durante o dia dos namorados
no fim de semana dos namorados eles
resolveram fazer durante o fim-de-semana
levar o circo voador de volta pro a dor
quem fez isso foi pela chamada anos e
queria estar sempre envolvido com um
projeto de música incríveis eles fizeram
agora a olimpíada aquela música e se
liga e tocou num ponto que é jeito a
gente também estava junto e aí a gente
foi convidado para poder fazer uma
campanha para o exagerado 30 que foi
esse projeto do circo voador está de
volta na quadra e chamou vários
embaixadores pessoas relevantes na rede
social para poder postar respeito disso
fazer o upgrade do circo voador
depois que acabou o projeto também foi
chamado pessoalmente pelo nome da
empresa falou arnaldo se não fosse pelo
case de vocês se não fosse pela idéia de
vocês o evento não tinha virado desde
que os embaixadores entraram na parada
mudou totalmente de figura
beleza aí você pensa em lançar um cara
veio aqui pediu para aplaudirem antes de
falar qualquer coisa falsa a ideia de
infância falou do skate na empresa dele
mas que tem a ver uma coisa com a outra
onde é que ao despertar
a colher a adequação ao tema
eu não sei se vocês perceberam a verdade
é que eu não tinha percebido até semana
passada quando eu comecei a montar o tag
que meus sonhos de infância sérios
através da minha empresa eu não sabia eu
não tinha nenhuma noção eu acho que é
muito claro para vocês agora pelo que eu
falei tanto graficamente o futebol não
fui idade do flamengo mas joguei com o
10 do flamengo
o basquete nem perto mas conhecido ea
música hoje em dia eu sou parceiro
oficial da empresa que faz as maiores
produções de música do país
então o despertar para o qual eu chamo
vocês não é uma fuga total da realidade
presente
eu não quero que ninguém saia daqui eu
despertei vou sair da faculdade vou
viajar o mundo vou largar minha casa vou
mudar tudo vou dar uma volta total na
minha vida não despertar para o qual eu
convido vocês é um despertar para a
própria vida pode ser incrivelmente boa
dito que ela já é que eu não fazia ideia
os meus sonhos avião é realizado através
da empresa até sentar para montar sua
palestra
se não tivesse sido convidado para vir
aqui hoje eu continuaria não sabendo não
espera então fica aqui o meu convite fez
despertar tentem ver de que maneira o
sonho de vocês já não está se
materializando na realidade de vocês no
dia a dia
saia dessa realidade e ansiosa e falsa
expectativa
a gente consegue uma coisa e que atrás
de outra que é uma coisa e vai atrás de
outro eu estou falando isso mas eu sou
péssimo início de novo ela não sabia
disso até agora só sei graça de novo
vocês se vocês pensarem
quando falei que para estar no ted era
meu sonho não era só não só empurra
maltese por ser um fã do evento
se vocês perceberem de novo que tem como
basquete
o futebol a música o cantor
o atleta ele tem oportunidade única de
inspirar pessoas
no fundo no fundo isso é tudo que eu
sempre quis
poderia um dia ter um espaço para
inspirar alguém claro seria muita
pretensão eu achar que vão inspirar cada
um de vocês mas se ao menos um de vocês
aqui e pensar no que eu falei e
conseguir levar a vida por um lugar
melhor
já vai ser sem dúvidas no sonho e por
isso não podia deixar de agradecer no
brio
[Aplausos]
[Música]